bye
now in ordinary life anger for example
is such an internal action is located in
the liver plato even assigns the liver
something still higher something which
is even regarded by some as the highest
function of all that is prophesying or
the gift of speaking of holy and eternal
things in a non-rational manner
but the movement which the individual
has in his liver heart and so on cannot
be regarded as holy reflected into
itself rather it is present in such a
manner that has already taken on a
corporeal aspect in him and has an
animal existence turning outward to
external reality
hegel in paragraph 326 proposes for us
um
one possible contender
for being that organ that is mediating
between the the spiritual individuality
what we might call our our
spiritual consciousness
and all the other organs of the body uh
and he talks about the liver
so you know that seems probably a bit
strange to the the late modern reader
because we don't think of the liver
doing much other than helping us
to digest things and every once in a
while getting injured and causing us
problems right
so
why talk about the liver well he he
tells you you know a few things here
he says in ordinary life anger
for example is such an internal action
is located in the liver people
i mean we know this isn't the case now
although getting angry a lot isn't good
for your liver i suppose
anymore that it's good for other parts
of your body but
you know this is a common view that that
you could localize
particular
emotions or effects in terms of the
humors that were going on and the liver
produces one of the humors the the holos
the bile right
and melancholia uh you know black bile
disease was closely connected with anger
in any case what are we talking about
here so hegel is saying
look with this maybe there is that that
reflexive relation going on
and anger maybe is i mean if you think
about the way anger works is an emotion
it is self-regarding it has to do with
the relationship not just of you know
stimulus to to your response
but rather of the perception of wrong
being done so there's already like moral
conceptions
there's interrelations with other people
so perhaps that's you know something a
good contender for something that would
be in fact uh spiritual geistika right
in the hegelian sense
furthermore
he says uh plato associated the liver
with something yet higher this is kind
of a backhanded compliment though
he says
which is regarded by by some people as
the highest function of all not by hegel
by the way uh but but some people
thought that sort of an unmediated
relationship to the divine
you know around the time that he's
writing was the best thing that you
should be going after these are the
people who stressed intuition you
remember back to hegel's criticisms of
intuition in the preface
so he he goes on and he says plato
you know said that it had to do with
prophesying or the gift of speaking of
holy and eternal things in a
non-rational manner
now what's the problem here the liver is
not going to be a suitable candidate
neither is the heart which is another
organ that people uh sometimes when
they're thinking about you know the body
would like to associate with oh that's
where my my emotions lie
we engage in all this metaphorical stuff
and i think some people really do think
that the human heart uh
is this this locus of the person i mean
why not locate it say in the pancreas or
in the tip of your finger well you know
these organs are supposed to be doing
some sort of unifying task so hegel says
why doesn't this work
it says the movement which the
individual has in his liver heart and so
on cannot be regarded as wholly
reflected into itself
why not
even if it's partially
reflected into itself it's also
focused on external reality so if we
take anger for an example okay so anger
is self-regarding um and it does have to
do not only with your own view of
yourself but your view of yourself in
relation to other people
and you know moral
obligations or expectations all that
sort of stuff that's true but it is
primarily
um you know doing something out there in
the world and so hegel is saying that's
that's it's somewhat reflective but not
it's not what we're looking for here so
he says
the the movement cannot be regarded as
wholly reflected into itself rather it
is present in such a manner that has
already taken on a corporeal aspect in
him
and he has an animal existence turning
outwards to external reality and again
anger great example
anger can stem from a lot of rational
considerations but it is in in many
respects an animal like response
and you know you might think of you know
epictetus for example observing that
when we give in to anger and we're just
totally out of control we're like wild
beasts we're like the beasts of prey not
like sheep and nice things that you know
basically just want to eat and copulate
and that's a whole problem by itself not
like little clever foxes but more like
lions and wolves that want to tear into
the other people the rest of the world
sometimes even ourselves if we get angry
enough
so
the liver is not going to work as a
candidate so what will that's that's
where we have to go next
the nervous system on the other hand is
the immediate repose of the organism in
its movement the nerves themselves it is
true are again the organs of that
consciousness which is already immersed
in its outward directed activity brain
and spinal cord however may be
considered as the immediate presence of
self-consciousness a presence which
abides within itself is not objective
and also does not look outwards insofar
as the the moment of being which this
organ has is a being for another that is
is an outer existence it is a dead thing
and no longer the presence of
self-consciousness this being within
itself however
is by its very nature a fluid system in
which the circles cast into it
immediately dissolve and in which no
lasting distinction is expressed
meanwhile as spirit itself is not
abstractly simple but a system of
movements in which it differentiates
itself into moments but in this very
differentiation remains free and as
spirit articulates its body into a
variety of functions and allots one
particular part for only one function
so too the fluid being of its being
within self can be thought of as
articulated into parts
and it seems that it must be thought of
in this way because the being of spirit
which in the brain
is reflected into itself is a is itself
again only a middle term between
spirit's pure essence and it's corporeal
articulation a middle term which
therefore must partake of the nature of
both the corporeal aspect must therefore
also be present in the middle term in
the form of immediate being
in 326 hegel had ruled out several
different organs as
possible contenders for having that that
kind of
circularity or reflexivity of being what
mediates the you know parts of the body
the organs of the body with something
that is corporeal to it to a degree in
its causality but is but is not truly
corporeal which is spirit
now he's going to let the cat out of the
bag and say okay it's the nervous system
or at least part of
the nervous system that is doing that
work and here we're getting something
like a philosophy of mind in the sense
that we're used to today
hegel is going to view the nervous
system as a whole
as performing the the function that that
we were just talking about so he says
the nervous system
on the other hand is the immediate
repose of the organism in its movement
which is a little bit of a strange way
to talk about it the repose of the
individual in its its movement right
what is its dynamic right uh the nervous
system is able to take into account
what's going on in the rest of the body
now he goes on and he says the nerves
themselves are the organs of that
consciousness which is already immersed
in its outward directed activity right
so the nerves are you know sort of a
mediator to
the rest of
the body and thereby to the external
reality
that lies outside of the scope of the
body so the nerves perform a function
the nerves are sort of channels of
communication they are not by themselves
doing a lot of reflexive work although
you know feedback loops can be can be
set up with them i suppose
so he goes on and he says
brain and spinal cord may be considered
as the immediate presence of
self-consciousness
that's going to be a very important
phrase
the immediate
presence
of self-consciousness
not all of self-consciousness is just
what's going on in the brain or spinal
cord
as a matter of fact you know strictly
speaking self-consciousness
from a hegelian perspective is not even
just located within the self you can see
that in the dialectic of
self-consciousness at the beginning of
that section the other assumes a role
and so you lose you might say a part of
yourself to the other but put that aside
for right now because remember we're
back in the reason section reason is
sure of itself it's worked through all
that stuff in self-consciousness so how
does it work for for this
he says
brain and spinal cord may be considered
as the immediate presence of
self-consciousness a presence which
abides within itself
is not objective and also does not look
outwards in so far as it's considering
itself
says insofar as the moment of being
which this organ has
is a being for another that is an outer
existence
it is a dead thing and no longer the
presence of self-consciousness
now that is a fascinating thing to say
because what does that mean
insofar
as the brain is primarily being looked
at
from the outside say by dissection
or by doing uh brain surgery
or by doing experimentation on as we did
you know
uh you know the unfortunate survivors of
head injuries in world war one
or for example using mri imagery to try
to say oh well this is exactly what's
going on
something is being lost in the reduction
of it to the objective
it turns the brain into just whatever
you know
science the natural science of today
can reveal it to be which isn't its full
being
so
interestingly here's an implication this
is a little bit of a digression here if
hegel is correct in this
this means that the whole question of
whether consciousness
is reducible to the brain or whether you
know we have something like a cartesian
dualism where there's spirit and then
you know the corporeal organ
that's kind of a non-starter actually
within the hegelian framework because of
course you have an organ
but that organ itself can be understood
in two ways in an objective way which
treats it essentially as a dead thing
even if it treats it as a
supposedly living system
and then
the other way which is to say it is it
is infused with or it is integrated with
spirit
and not just in like you know high
performing individuals everybody
so he goes on now i mean consider that
too another digression
hegel has no problem with a sort of
evolutionary perspective on the
development of human being and all that
at a certain point we get a creature
whose brain
function
is able to be a sufficient vehicle
for spirit for geist
for something that we could never guess
would have come on the scene and we we
get to know sort of according to hegel
after the fact after it's gone through
its process of development
keep that think about that a bit
anyway going back to the brain and and
all that he says
insofar as the the moment of being which
his organ has is a being for another
uh it's a dead thing no longer the
presence of self-consciousness the being
within itself however is by its very
nature a fluid system in which the
circles cast into it immediately
dissolved the nice little metaphor
throwing things into the pond and the
circles disappear
and in which no lasting distinction is
expressed and that is what what spirit
for the individual spirit
is it's a fluid system and it uses the
brain to do so now hegel is using this
term here one that he doesn't use all
that often
being within self
uh in zeke's help sign he's not using
anzine in itself being in itself nor is
he talking about phrasic design being
for itself nor is he even saying you
know uh being for in and for itself
right on and for his exige he's saying
in zeke zelp's sign and i don't want to
go go
you know overboard on this but there's
there's uh something that's worth
pointing out here
uh there's what we might call a
reflexive intensity going on here
zeke and zelpst here are both doing
similar things
in zeke
in itself i mean on zeke would be uh in
itself in the more proper sense but in
zeke in
itself exalts
what that is
so to have in zeek zelp's sign
being
within itself
means to have a certain what i just
called reflexive intensity
of being
that means that it has greater being
that means that because of that
reflexive relation it has greater being
this is a really tricky
concept that hegel is just sort of
plowing through without explaining to us
at this point
let's go on and see where he's going now
he says
it was a fluid system meanwhile as
spirit itself is not abstractly simple
but a system of movements in which it
differentiates itself into moments but
this in this very differentiation
remains free and as spirit articulates
its body into a variety of functions and
a lot one particular part for only one
function
so too the fluid being of its being
within self can be thought of as
articulated into parts
thought of that doesn't mean that spirit
actually does have parts but it's got
something analogous what we might call
functions
so he says it seems it must be thought
of in this way because the being of
spirit which in the brain is reflected
into itself
is again only a middle term between what
spirit's pure essence over here
and the rest of the body and the outside
world over here
brain
is a mediator it is a connector you
might say for spirit and the outside
world
so he says it's a middle term which
therefore must partake of the nature of
both
the corporeal aspect must therefore be
present in the middle term
in the form of immediate being this is
precisely why
the brain can be viewed from a certain
perspective
as reducible to say its structures or
its cells or what can be revealed as
areas of electrical activity
but there's more going on
than just that in the way in which
spirit is using
or in framing itself with the brain
the spiritually organic being has at the
same time the necessary aspect of an
inert enduring existence the former qua
the extreme of being for self must step
back and have this ladder as the other
extreme over against it
which is then the object on which the
spiritually organic being acts as cause
if now the brain and spinal cord
together constitute that corporeal being
for self of spirit
the skull and vertebral column form the
other extreme to it an extreme which is
separated off that is the solid inert
thing
when however anyone thinks of the proper
location of spirit's outer existence it
is not the back that comes to mind but
only the head
therefore in examining a way of knowing
like the one we are now dealing with we
can be satisfied with this reason not a
very bad reason in this case in order to
confine this existence to the skull
should it occur to anyone to think of
the back as the location of spirit
insofar as by it too knowing and doing
are no doubt sometimes partly driven in
and partly driven out this would be no
proof at all that the spinal cord must
be taken as included in the indwelling
seat of spirit because this proves too
much
for one may equally recall that there
are other popular external ways too for
getting at the activity of spirit in
order to stimulate or inhibit it
the vertebral column is then rightly
ruled out if you like that the skull
alone does not contain the organs of
spirit is as well explained as many
another doctrine of philosophy of nature
for this was previously excluded from
the notion of this relation and for this
reason the skull was taken for the
aspect of outer existence or if we are
not to be allowed to recall the notion
of the relation then certainly
experience teaches that as it is with
the ayakua organ that we see
so it is not with the skull that we
murder steal write poetry and so forth
that is the reason why we must also
refrain from using the expression organ
for that significance of the skull which
is still to be mentioned
for although it is commonly said that
reasonable men pay attention not to the
word but to the thing itself
yet this does not give us permission to
describe a thing in terms inappropriate
to it
for this is at once incompetence and
deceit to fancy and to pretend that one
merely has not the right word and to
hide from oneself that really one has
failed to get hold of the thing itself
that is the notion
if one had the notion then one would
also have the right word
what has been determined here in the
first instance is only that just as the
brain is the living head the skull is
the kapput mortum
you'll notice that paragraph 328 ends
with some
discussion by hegel actually more
criticism by hegel
of people who are in his view being
sloppy with language as a reflection of
a sloppy consciousness a sloppy way of
thinking that's that's not using
concepts that's not using the notion the
begin
but rather perhaps something like
picture thinking
or something even even lower
he has this nice catchphrase if one had
the notion if one actually had a grasp
on the the grasper the graph
then one would have the right word so it
doesn't do any good to say oh i've got
the notion in my head but i just can't
find the language if you actually have
the notion you can express yourself
adequately to another person so that
they can understand what it is that
you're saying they can they can have
evidence that you you can you grasp the
concept so that's sort of at the end of
328 and he's going to say that um
this is you know incompetence and deceit
fancy and pretending one has not the
right word and hiding from oneself that
really one has failed to get hold of the
thing itself that that has
not worked through
the notion now a little bit earlier in
that paragraph he's going to say
even if we put the notion aside you can
see that this thing this proposal is not
going to work so let's take a look then
at that proposal
first thing to point out
is that there's kind of a
two-sidedness here right we've got
spiritually organic being which is part
of what we were just talking about in
the previous paragraphs
uh you know the spiritual individual is
this fluid dynamic system
and not not fluid dynamics right fluid
and dynamic
and it's it's corporeal in so far as
it's causal but it's not in essence
corporeal
you know is in the sense of being
reducible to configurations of matter
um there's more going on there and then
hegel says look it expresses itself
um you know naturally in in a way that's
that's objectifiable
he says it has the the necessary aspect
of an inert enduring substance
so he says the former quad the extreme
of being for self must step back and
have this ladder as the other extreme
against it
which is then the object on which the
spiritually organic being
acts as cause so we've got passive we
have active right we have
spiritual we have corporeal and so we've
got these two polarities there that are
that are connected together
now he says if the brain and spinal cord
together constitute that corporeal
being for self of spirit we we saw that
the brain
the spinal cord the nervous system that
part is what allows that
reflexivity right
hegel is interested now
in determining what of this mess here in
the center we're going to use
to talk about
uh where spirit is is really doing stuff
and now he's doing it for his own sake
he's also doing it in order for us to
help understand the physiognomist and
ultimately the phrenologist so he's
doing in part because he thinks that
this is on to something he's also doing
it in part because he thinks these
people the phrenologists and
physiognomists are going to go along
partly the right way and then screw
things up
so we have to see
where we're going with this
so hegel is going to uh
you might say strip off different
alternative uh
things that could be the organ
so he says
the brain and spinal cord together
constitute that being for self a spirit
the skull and vertebral column form the
other extreme to it an extreme that is
separated off the solid inert thing so
we can draw a line here right
this is part of that inert enduring
existence
of the skull right the spinal column
the stuff that protects it i mean your
skull does grow right especially when
you're a little baby but your skull
isn't doing a hell of a lot other than
protecting that as we say that you know
that gordon side right
so he goes on and he's going to say look
the skull
it's not an organ that is doing
something in terms of consciousness this
is a little bit later we're going to
come back to the discussion of the
spinal column in a moment he says
the skull you know was taken for the
aspect of outer existence
we can certainly experience or certainly
experience teaches that as it is with
the iqua organ that we see
it's not
with the skull
that we do intellectual things like
murder steal
write poetry and i say well murdering
and stealing aren't really intellectual
things well they sure are because you
actually have to do a lot of thinking uh
well at least some thinking in order to
do them and it's not done with the skull
it's done with
the brain the brain is the
the driver there the skull is just the
protector right the helmet you might say
and so he says that's the reason why we
must refrain from using the expression
organ for that significance of the skull
which still has to be mentioned what is
that significance of the skull that
still has to be mentioned what
phrenology is going to be doing looking
at the bumps
on your skull and trying to deduce
things
about what's inside based on uh what's
going on with the outside
so he says
going back now to the the spinal column
here's kind of an interesting
observation so we've already cut off the
skull and the vertebral column the bones
we don't really need those at this point
in order to talk about this this
reflexive uh dynamic
of spirit being for itself
what about the spinal co the spinal cord
so he says
whenever one thinks of the proper
location of spirits outer existence it's
not the back
right that's where your spine goes it
goes all the way down to your butt
essentially it's not your back that we
tend to think of
but rather the head
so
he he goes on he says in examining a way
of knowing like the one we're now
dealing with what is that phrenology and
physiognomy
we can be satisfied with this reason not
a very bad reason but in order to
confine this existence to the skull
should it occur to anyone to think of
the back as the location of spirit
insofar as by it knowing and doing are
no doubt sometimes partly driven in and
partly driven out this would be no proof
at all the spinal cord must be taken as
included in the indwelling seat
of spirit where where is it that spirit
is doing its thing
it's not in the spinal column in a
certain way you could say the spinal
column is just a very
complex cluster of nerves your spinal
column is not doing the thinking for you
now you can say yeah what about people
who are born with just you know this the
brain stem and not the brain okay the
hegel would probably go along with you
on that but they're not doing a hell of
a lot they're not living
anything like a a you know human life in
the sense of being self-aware
being reflexive taking positions on
themselves
as far as we know i mean maybe maybe
there are some but i don't know of that
so he goes on and he says
in any case it would prove too much
you may easily equally recall there's
other popular external ways for getting
at the activity of spirit in order to
stimulate or inhibit it the vertebral
column then is rightly ruled out
if you like
and then he goes on to talk about the
skull so what we can do here is say
it's not the
back
whether it be the nervous system or the
bones
it's not the
bone part of the head it's the
squishy brain part of the head
that is the indwelling seat of spirit
so again keep in mind that hegel is
interested in this not only for its own
sake but so that he can follow along
with these pseudo sciences and say well
they got this part right but here's
where they're going to go
way off into crazy territory
and now he's about to to reveal some of
that to us in the paragraphs to come